نريد أن نذهب الآن إلى أه فريد Pliken من
أه يعيش معنا أنا أفهم أه
هل أنت هناك نعم هناك أنت أه لذلك
أفهم أنك واجهت بعض الصعوبات
أه نفسك أه أخبرنا بالضبط ما الذي
يحدث هناك
نعم لذلك أنا في  ميدان sukharevskaya
الذي يبعد حوالي كيلومترين عن
المكان الذي كان من المفترض أن تكون الاحتجاجات فيه في الأصل
في ميدان لوبيانكا ، لكن
هذا تم تطويقه تمامًا ، كنا
هناك قبل ذلك بقليل
وجود شرطة هائل في كيم
، تم إغلاق جميع الطرق هناك كما
ترون هناك  الكثير من
رجال شرطة مكافحة الشغب موجودون بالفعل هنا في الميدان
وأنت على حق تمامًا ، لقد تم احتجازي
لفترة وجيزة من قبل شرطة مكافحة الشغب الروسية
أيضًا حتى أظهرت لهم
اعتمادي أنهم كانوا يأخذونني إلى
سيارة شرطة ثم
سمحوا لي بالذهاب  ولكن كان هناك
بالفعل في الميدان هنا على
الرغم من عدم وجود العديد من المتظاهرين هنا
، كانت هناك مجموعة من الاعتقالات
الجارية بالفعل ، لذا بدا الأمر
كما لو
أن الشرطة هي التي قامت بأعمال الشغب  الشرطة ، الشرطة العسكرية ،
لقد ظهروا هنا بسرعة كبيرة
، ويبدو أن هذا هو
الاهتمام التالي الذي يمكنك أن ترى أنهم
حقًا
يطاردون خطًا متشددًا للغاية
وقد رأينا هذا
بشكل أساسي منذ أه منذ أن وصل رجال الشرطة إلى
هنا
أم أنهم كانوا يحتجزون للتو
الكثير من الأشخاص ، لذا يبدو حقًا وكأنه
سياسة عدم التسامح مطلقًا ، فهذه عملية
احتجاز أخرى هنا ،
لقد تم اعتقالهم بالقوة وهم
يحتجزون الكثير من الأشخاص وأيضًا
بالمناسبة الكثير من الصحفيين ، لذلك فعلت  أرى
اثنين من الصحفيين الآخرين ، ليس أنا فقط
الذين كنت أقوم بتقديم التقارير ، وأثناء
قيامهم بتقديم التقارير ، تم احتجازهم
، وكما لدينا هنا ، يتم
احتجاز آخر الآن ،
لذا يمكنك أن ترى أن الشرطة
تتجه بكل تأكيد إلى
أه  خط متشدد للغاية هنا
يتجه فورًا إلى الأشخاص الذين يعتقلون على الفور
الكثير من الأشخاص
الذين يبدو أنهم لا يريدون
حتى أن يتمكن هذا الاحتجاج من الاجتماع
معًا لأن جمهور um pro
navalny wha  لقد فعلوا ذلك ،
لقد أعلنوا هذا متأخرًا جدًا
لمحاولة التمكن من
الالتقاء فعليًا ، وبمجرد
أن يبدأوا في التجمع هنا ،
يمكننا بالفعل متابعة هذا الأمر ، هناك
احتجاز آخر يجري هنا
يمكننا متابعة  قليلاً
حتى تتمكن من رؤية أي
شخص يأتي إلى هنا بشكل أساسي آسف ،
يتم القبض على الكثير منهم على الفور
من قبل الشرطة ولمجرد
إعطائك فكرة صغيرة عما يحدث بعد ذلك
عندما يتم نقلهم إلى هذه الحافلات هنا
ونوع من البحث من خلالها  الحافلة
هنا مكان احتجاز آخر ،
هناك نوع من الزنزانة في
تلك الحافلات حيث يتم
اصطحاب هؤلاء الأشخاص إليك ، يمكنك
رؤية هذا الرجل الذي يأخذ آه هذا الرجل هنا يتم
تفتيشه الآن
وهو ينقل إلى حافلة شرطة أخرى ،
لذا نعم أعني الشرطة  في الخارج بكامل قوتها ،
ليس من
دواعي سروري أن أذهب إلى هناك ، فأنا
أتعرض للضغط الآن ، من
الواضح أن الشرطة لديها يد ثقيلة حقًا
هنا في
محاولة لوقف هذه الاحتجاجات
بأي ثمن تقريبًا